sinb io the nickname of synthetic
biology perhaps the biggest oxymoron of
the 21st century that you probably
haven't heard of sin bio is a field of
science that goes beyond creating
genetically modified organisms or GMOs
which have been contested around the
world this is GMO on the edge extreme
genetic modifying that doesn't just
change up DNA but makes it from scratch
how through a computer of course
software that can be programmed to spit
out DNA code that code is then injected
into an organism which is fooled into
thinking it is the real thing
sugar is the key here needed to
synthesize the DNA back in 2010
researchers use this flow DNA to create
the first artificial chromosome head
biologist J craig Venter called it quote
the first self-replicating species we've
had on the planet whose parent is a
computer the new technology is being
used to create a whole new menu of
Franken food this year researchers at
New York University successfully created
a completely synthetic yeast cell and
the biotech company evolved a polished
off its symbiote version of vanilla
called vanillin vanillin will be the
first synthetic food additive to hit
supermarkets coconut oil cacao and
saffron are also in development the best
part for the food industry all of it can
be called natural even organic and
escaped GMO labeling beyond food sin
biotechnology is being used in household
cleaning products cosmetics fragrances
and medicine it's no wonder sin BIOS in
Wester czar multinational agricultural
chemical and pharmaceutical companies
they want a piece of an industry expect
it to be worth 40 billion dollars by
2020 energy companies want in two giants
like BP Chevron and Exxon are all
pouring billions into research of
synthetic algae
that could be transformed into fuel and
wouldn't you know the US military also
wants a piece of the action the
Department of Defense's tech wing DARPA
has seen a bump in its budget to work on
bio design research to create synthetic
life forms that could be immortal
immortal combat thus far symbiote have
gone largely unregulated being so new
many government agencies don't know what
to do with it but the dawn of
frankenfood is being watched closely by
environmental justice organizations Neff
Don yo of etc group warns of the effects
on farmers who displace farmers from
lagoon and and communities friends of
the earth says symbiosis heavy reliance
on sugar will lead to more deforestation
to make way for sugar plantations and
yet dr. frankenfood and the companies at
back him carry on working may be to feed
the world and definitely to make a
profit